what was your longest time that you
spent in jail Brandon um uh a few months
over a year few months over a year that
was consecutive yeah yeah yeah so at
that point I had made it I graduated to
the penitentiary for sure yeah well cuz
after if you get a year or more you
don't go to County you go to the yeah
County Jail is by definition for under a
year yep over a year by definition is
prison what was your longest 10 days 10
days six six months Jesus okay so when
you went down for this Penitentiary bid
you were aware that you were going you
had to surrender yourself you knew that
you were going no you didn't so I was
actually fighting the case um I I'd
originally the the the the charge
stemmed from uh a prescription fraud
right I I had buddy of mine had stole a
a pad from a doctor and he penciled out
me a few perco setes and a few being
yeah I like it it was from a dentist pad
so you couldn't write like a big script
so it was like 10 or 15 cuz it was for
like the oxycodone 30 milligrams which
is like a higher amount or dosage than a
dentist would normally ever write so you
had to kind of keep it like mellow to
not look
suspicious and uh i' had went to the
pharmacy it was actually during the time
we were filming um number two yeah yeah
jackass number two and I was I was Ill
one day and and uh I was I had this
leather jacket on with all these
different pockets and I I was like
rumaging through my stuff hoping to find
something now when you say ill you mean
dop sick yeah yeah yeah withdrawing and
I was trying to find something to hold
me over through the day and I found this
pad this piece of paper so I went to the
the pharmacy down the street
and committed frog yeah
totally undermine that you wrote it out
yourself no it was already written out
oh but it didn't matter it was I I
intentionally handed it over so you
committed fraud yes you you pled not
guilty when you knew damn well that you
were guilty I forget what my plead was
but I was fighting it and my my my
lawyer ultimately got me uh a sentence
um of 11 and a half months to
23 but I was going to serve 30 weekends
in 6 months house arrest is what it
equated to oh so you had ample
opportunity to put your prison pocket to
use I and that's exactly one of the
reasons why I um ended up going to
prison so every uh every little weekend
release you load up the prison pocket
all day long which which which was
really just prolonging the inevitably
because when I got sober I actually had
to have hemorrhoid surgery because my
[__] doubled as a suitcase for so
many years
yeah what's what's the most you put up
there uh I would just it wasn't about
how much it was really the way that I
put it up there like it was just raw and
rough it was like a raping aggressive
yeah very aggressive Rock what was your
process though did you have to like make
a little uh what they call a bullet dud
my process was just quick and fast like
I'd sit in the parking lot of the jail
and my buddy be dropped me off and I'd
rip off the cigarette pack uh the the
the cellophane I'd throw the bags in
there and I'd take a lighter and I'd
light that to make which is think about
the edge like a burnt and then just spit
on it and just shove it
up yeah like a a butthole key bump just
spit on it yeah enjoyed that a
lot yeah yeah yeah so dude one time we
were on tour with [__] face Unstoppable
and and I was we were in Europe and and
I we happen to be in this area where
they sold a lot of SM Mac and I didn't
have any money I'm like bam give me 100
bucks he's like [__] no I know what you
want it for and I wouldn't leave him
alone and he's like um he's like shove
this rock up your ass I'll give you a
hundred bucks I shove the rock up my ass
a real
friend he really cared about my
wellbeing that day and uh we have all
this on footage too
actually so so uh I then go get the
heroin forget about the rock being up my
ass and and I wait hold on like you
forgot the rock was up your yeah yeah
cuz I'm like comos at this point 100
bucks worth of smacks like yeah so we do
the show and uh all of a sudden you know
I would open up for [__] face and I
would come out as uh pill Collins you
know Phil Collins the song in the air of
the night yeah I cuz I would go on tour
with those guys but I was just the
[__] biggest [__] because I there
was no relevance or connection with me
with the tour like I played no music I
was in no instruments I mean I'm not
going to go that far there was
absolutely a relevance and a connection
like
you're you know you're you're you're in
Bam's world and it's like uh you're
opening up the show with with craziness
the show is all about being crazy well I
wasn't in I wasn't opening it yet this
is the buildup to where I found my my
place in that tour bus because I would
just like bam was about it and I'm his
best friend so he just let me do
whatever but the rest of the guys in the
band who actually cared about playing
music [__] could didn't stand me cuz
I just like made life hell and they had
to endure my [__] was Jess in the band
Jess Chad uh oh wow Chad Ginsburg and
Chad actually came up with this idea
they're like Novak you have to do
something besides just be hell for us so
why don't you like open up for us and
I'm like all right but I don't play any
have no like you're like GG Allen so
here we go ex dud you spot it you got
it so so like all right instead of Phil
Collins You're going to be pill Collins
and and you're going to open up and
you're going to come out on stage with
like if it's a 18 and over you'll be
naked but if it's or if it's a 21 and
over you'll be naked but if it's 18 and
over you have to wear a pair of thongs a
bottle of wine cuz that's all I drank
and the sigs and and just lip song I
mean i' sing along karaoke the in the
air of the night and just throw my wine
and [__] smoke and just be a GG Allen
and intro the band and as the
big like would come on I'd intro bam and
he'd run out and Drop Kick Me and then
the [__] concer would kick off did
did you get any permanent damage from
being drop kicked by bam not that I'm
aware of I know that Dave England is
acutely aware of really he finally just
had surgery on his neck oh yeah yeah
yeah I I think heroin helped me out in a
lot of those ways yeah I was like a
[__] wet noodle a [__] UI crash
that's why they always live yeah um so
anyway so I I'm now designated to be
this guy who opens up for the band and
and and while I'm doing the concert and
Bam jump kicks me this [__] rock
shoots out of my ass and I start
bleeding I start bleeding all over the
[__] concert like for real how big
was this rock it was just like like that
and did you have to spit on it to get it
in uh I'm sure I Spit on everything to
get in my ass it was just like that I
came in
so it wasn't quite a pool
ball not not quite a q ball that'd be
impressive though but but absolutely a
golf ball yeah it was like it was like
that it was a golf ball you know you
know who filmed it Chris seagull he was
on that tour with us Chris and he has
the footage so my fiance at the time was
on tour with us and you had a fiance at
the time that's why yeah she's now no
longer she when she died no no no no no
she had she came to her [__] senses
and like dude why am I with you like so
so she is like this really good woman
and we end up they take me to the
hospital and Chris is filming the whole
thing and they have me in this room and
all these doctors come in they're making
their
rounds and I'm telling you have the rock
to show the doctors no The Rock was long
gone but I was explaining the story and
and that rock probably be worth
something
today it was worth 100 bucks that one
day to my [__] so I'm like dude I I
put this rock up my ass and and it's
bleeding profusely and and they're
looking at it and my ex fiance is there
and she's like this is this is you're
you're his ex- fiance and she's like
yeah and they say could you come outside
the room for a second and they bring her
out and and they're saying he's saying
it's from a rock which has caused this
like profuse bleeding and and and
inflammatory situation this isn't from a
rock it's from years and years of damage
like you like how could you be his
fiance and he's enduring years of
[__] damage to his [__] alluding
to the fact that I might have been a
homosexual and then I was lying wow do
you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is sto's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get sto's hot sauce Freer butthole plus
sto's butthole Destroyer and steo butt
wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude